welcome to CBS this morning we begin
with this it is another historic day on
Capitol Hill where the initial vote on
two articles of impeachment against
President Trump is expected in just a
few hours the House Judiciary Committee
began a highly-charged meeting on the
issue last night Democrats once again
laid out their charges that the
president abused his power or his own
political benefit and obstructed their
investigation and both parties are
calling this proceeding a sad day for
America this morning we're also learning
about a new White House defense strategy
Nancy Cordes is in the room where the
hearing will resume this morning Nancy
what's next in this process well 40
lawmakers made their opening statements
in this room last night this morning the
true debate begins Republicans will try
to change the articles of impeachment
strike parts out Democrats will move to
block them this is the final step before
a full house vote today we begin
consideration of two articles of
impeachment against President Donald J
Trump this is the most corrupt rigged
railroad job I've seen in my entire life
this is not a rush to judgment it's a
rush to justice the two sides debated
well into the night well any of them say
that the presidents of the United States
should not drag foreign powers into our
elections a record of a Democratic Party
who's lost all moorings of fairness and
good taste that's what we're seeing here
Democrats defended their articles of
impeachment one for abuse of power the
other obstruction of Congress refusing
to turn over even one document that's
what requires us to act now even
President Nixon cooperated with Congress
but president Trump has thumbed his nose
at constitutional power the abuse of
power article argues President Trump
corruptly solicited the government of
Ukraine to publicly announce
investigations into a political opponent
President Donald J Trump wielded the
enormous powers of the presidency to
cheat in the 2020 election
looking's channeled the president's
charged that these articles are
impeachment light what we're debating
here in my opinion is the weakest case
in history
whatever happened to quid pro quo
extortion and bribery the Democrats have
been telling us it was clear the facts
were undisputed the evidence was
overwhelming except it wasn't any of
those things and now it's all gone
Democrats hit back wrong is wrong from
your workplace to the White House
there's no times to spare here no time
to waste
this is a constitutional crime spree it
comes as new polls show public support
for impeachment is holding steady about
forty five percent think President Trump
should be removed from office this is
about one basic fact the Democrats have
never accepted the will of the American
people
The Smoking Gun is already reloaded and
whether or not it gets fired that's up
to us it's a little late in the process
but last night the White House offered
up its most detailed explanation yet for
why the President withheld military aid
to Ukraine in this nine page memo from
the Office of Management and Budget they
argued that this hold was temporary and
part of a regularly used procedure but
several of the witness testified in this
room that they asked repeatedly why the
aid was being withheld and they were
never given that answer or any other
very interesting new details there Nancy
thank you very much